Hello everyone, and welcome to my talk,
Enterprise Agents Have a Structural
Problem.
A quick introduction about myself. I'm
Ishita Daga. I work as a machine
learning engineer in Tesla, and
I'm building enterprise agents for our
organization.
Before we get into the framework and the
solution space, I actually want to talk
about why these agents fail in the first
place.
So, when an agent gives a bad answer,
the first reflect that we have is that
we need a bigger model, we need a the
latest model,
we
want a model with a lot of context so
that it can hold a lot of information,
or we need to add a lot of knowledge
base in terms of dot MD files,
documents, or MCP servers, plugins, etc.
But, while all of these are fair
solutions, they're not
the answer to actually improving the
data agent itself.
Model
The agent actually
has
these three main problems.
One is ambiguity. So, it doesn't know
what table is right, what column is
right, which data source, or which
knowledge base to access when, which one
holds the
source of truth, or like the cleanest
information, which one is just a bit
more flexible. So, we have a lot of
these knowledge bases, but it's not
defined which one is the best,
um,
or
which one to use when.
So, ambiguity, I feel, is one big
problem.
Second is staleness. We all know context
updates so quickly. Um,
a lot of decisions change, a lot of
definition, KPIs, they change so often.
Processes, they get updated so often.
But,
to keep our data agents accurate, we
need to update this context, this
context life cycle.
And
that's a second part of
the problem.
The last one is preference, which is
more so capturing an individual or a
team preference on
what metric to use to answer a specific
question, how to use a query, or what
filters to use in a query.
Although we have like
a canonical query, let's say, each team
has a different preference on what
filters or what definitions to use. So,
this I feel is very open-ended problem,
still needs a lot of research, a lot of
um industries or the frontier labs are
actually working on solving this one.
So, let's start with the first one,
ambiguity.
The agent needs to understand
what source of truth to use, or what
knowledge base to use. It can't weight
all the knowledge bases equally. There
has to be a bit more structure to the
one it chooses
to answer a particular question.
In my opinion, the source of truth
actually is a hierarchy, which goes from
the cleanest, least flexible source of
truth to the messiest, uh but most
flexible, most dynamic source of truth.
And
the way to answer any question is to
start from the cleanest to the messiest
or the most dynamic one.
We have divided in
the sources of truth in three different
buckets uh for this framework. The first
one being the semantic layer, which is
the best source of truth, a very curated
list of all the different queries, KPI
definitions, metric uh or how to
calculate the metric, um
the business definitions, and everything
combined into just one semantic layer,
which the model can use to answer a
query. So, the agent just looks into the
semantic layer, finds the closest KPI,
and references all of these different
data points from that KPI to actually
give you an answer.
The second part is canonical tables.
These are most of the parametric tables
or um queries, sorry.
Where you give the agent all of a list
of different parametric queries, and it
sort of tries to understand which ones
can it use to actually answer your
question. It gives it a bit more
flexibility in choosing or writing its
own query or its own filters, etc. And
it can answer a bit more wider
set of questions.
The last one is the database graph,
which I feel is the most trickiest
because it takes a lot of effort, but it
gives you a lot of flexibility in the
kind of questions that can be answered.
So,
the idea here is you connect each table
to all the different columns uh
each table to the metric that
can be answered through this table and
vice versa and sort of create this
um enormous database graph that can be
served
to the
agent and it can answer or query on top
of it. Well, it is tricky, it is also
very difficult to
maintain or update. So, I feel if an
enterprise is approaching or adding
sources of truth, they should start
adding the first and the second layer
first. These are easy to set up, solve I
think
80% of the problems, and then the 20%
can be solved by the database graph.
Moving on to our second problem, which
is tailness. I think the word speaks for
itself. But, the context gets
rotten, or it gets deprecated, or
processes change so often that it's hard
to
maintain dot MD files, or keep on
updating your skills with the most
latest context. It's just not easy, and
we need a better solution for that.
My answer to this problem is creating a
context life cycle, which basically has
two different components. The first one
being embedding life
data sources, or knowledge sources.
By life, I mean something or the data
sources that are going to be always
updated, would be reviewed and well
curated, and always provide the
newest, or the
most up-to-date data. This can include
your GitHub, your
um CRM tools, your Tableau, or DBT,
semantic layers, whatever you want to
include can be there, but it has to be a
mandatory data source, like a a data
source that is updated most often.
The second part is a feedback loop,
which is something that a lot of
enterprise or data agents actually miss.
The idea here is you should be able to
log each and every uh
event. And by event, I mean whenever
someone says that this database is
incorrect, or this definition definition
is incorrect, or updated, or there's a
new way to calculate a metric, or the
there is a new filter that you need to
use. All of these events need to be
captured, logged, and
used to update your
data agent context. Once you have
captured these events, the second part
is to actually evaluate your data agent,
and you can do that by either curating
an evaluation suite with
human annotated questions or human
evaluations, or you can create an
automated evaluation where you see all
the questions that have been asked in
the last couple of days and the actual
answers and how close the new answers
are to the actually the actual answers.
So, I think there are a lot of ways you
can do that, but a lot of teams
do not focus on evaluation that much,
and which is why the agents actually
fail so often because you don't know
how the agent is progressing or
how is the performance. You don't keep a
track of that. So, I feel creating this
feedback loop or a context loop where
you log, evaluate, update the context
every or every so often is very
important.
The last problem is preference,
which is
a very subjective problem because
preferences they change very often in
terms of what kind of metric should be
used, what's the right calculation.
Different teams will calculate the same
metric differently or um use the same
query but different filters. So, there
is a lot of subjectivity which needs to
be captured, but it's very hard to do
that on individual or team level.
To give an example,
um so, let's say
there is team A and team B, and they
don't both want to calculate the average
time
uh taken for a particular milestone.
Team A calculates it by looking at the
previous milestones or completion of the
previous milestone to completion of the
current milestone, while team B actually
looks at the start of the current
milestone to the start of the next
milestone.
So, while
both of these are correct metrics or the
correct way to calculate the metric.
They both will give you very different
answers and it's just about preference.
We just need to understand
what an individual mean
when they say what's the average
milestone time.
So while this is a great question, I
feel the industry still does not have a
correct answer or correct way to solve
the problem itself.
I feel like there are sort of two ways
to solve it. One is a semantic layer,
which is something that I'm trying.
Wherein you store all the different ways
to calculate a metric as a semantic
layer and then the individual sort of
can prompt the model which one do they
want to use. So
you can solve it but still is not
storing the preference of the user. And
the second thing is you again bump into
the first challenge, which is ambiguity.
The
agent doesn't know
which metric is the right one. You still
have to prompt it.
Second part is agent memory, which is
your mem zero or like storing
memory.md file, but it still is not the
best way.
It stores your preference but it can't
understand the distinction between two
different metrics or which one to use
when.
So I feel there are ways to solve it but
none of the ways are actually solving
the preference problem itself.
What we actually want is a way to route
the agent to the right metric based on
who
what what a team or
which individual is using that agent. So
still an open-ended problem but
yeah, I think something we should work
on or
research on a bit more.
Which brings us to the end of this
presentation. So just to conclude, I
feel there are these three big problems,
ambiguity, staleness, and preference.
And what we really need to solve for is
a better structure, a better way to
manage the context and evaluate the
context. And then preference, which is
such an open-ended problem. It requires
not just understanding how the agent
works, but also embedding an individual
preference, like creating a hive mind
for your data agent.
That's about it. Thank you so much.